are you ready for more new Xbox one  features Microsoft is happy to keep them  coming I'm Tony in this game spot news  update as a whole lot more first off  Xbox one's arena feature is expanding to  help players create more tournaments for  games like killer instinct and halo wars  2 a new party overlay is also on the way  which will show who in your group is  talking at a given time more features  include the ability to share a looking  for group message or filter and follow  certain clubs and game hubs right from  your activity feed Microsoft is always  tweaking the Xbox one so be sure to  subscribe to stay up-to-date with all  the biggest changes these new features  will be available first to Xbox insiders  quote in the coming weeks though members  might see a few roll out sooner than  that for more xbox one talk you can  check out our lobby discussion on  whether or not we'll pick up project  Scorpio  [Music]